Professor: Ativa.
Professor: Transcrição e legendas pela comunidade Amara.org
Professor: em específicos de gravação.
Professor: Em nossa aula de diálogo, tem que ter um...
Aluno: E o que eu aparei que ele erra bem menos.
Professor: Então, olha para aquele vídeo para ver se está funcionando.
Professor: É possível também.
Professor: Muito obrigado.
Professor: Entradão, saída.
Professor: O meu...
Professor: Eu não sei se eu posso te fazer essa mais, ainda não.
Professor: Ou que seria melhor para ser mais rápido.
Professor: É isso aí.
Professor: Muito obrigado, professor.
Professor: Então, pelo menos, 1,5...
Professor: Transcrição e legendas pela comunidade Amara.org
Professor: Oh.
Professor: Aqui.
Professor: Esses daqui são sem microfone.
Professor: Viste.